my name is Otto elantra and I'm an
associate professor columbia university
at the top institute for research and
alzheimer disease in the aging brain of
columbia university
the overall goal of the research in my
lab is to find the therapy against the
Alzheimer disease that's it's a very
general way of the same things and to be
to be more specific we are we have
different strategies in the lab to to go
to to to achieve this goal so we are
trying to approach it from different
perspectives and and and if I have to
summarize these perspectives in a few in
a few words I should say that in one
kind of studies we are trying to to
understand what is the function of a
molecule that is called beta-amyloid and
this is a molecule made by men amino
acid when once there are made amino acid
together that those molecular called
peptides anyway this bed amyloid which
is produced in very high amount in the
brain of people with this disease and
this no nose would be very toxic to the
communication of the cells in the brain
and therefore to lead to memory
impairment so but we know that this
molecule is President the brain of
people throughout life just normal
healthy people and it is there in very
low amount and nobody knew what was the
function if I told that any function
this protein in this very low amount
what most of scientists thought was that
it was a kind of piece of garbage in the
brain of people with no relevance
whatsoever and instead we have started
working on it and we found that actually
they probably the very vital function of
this protein in very low amount is just
to be there to lead to normal memory so
without it we
cannot store information the brain we
cannot learn they will not be it normal
memory so I mean with all the study what
we think is that this molecule is there
it's necessary from memory and then for
some unknown reason we start making
people which with the disease are making
a lot of it and the fact is a lot just
makes the opposite of what it does in in
the normal brain so it's actually it
reduces memory when it is there in a
very high amount and so this is a very
very interesting characteristic and we
think that actually until the studies
were not there what people were doing to
understand the cause of the disease was
just to look at this from the very end
of it instead of trying to understand
you know it was a kind of a piece of a
puzzle it is missing to understand the
to understand how something which is
there becomes what is the beginning of
the of the end for for the poor memory
so in other words just to make things
more simple because simpler because
otherwise we get lost here is that now
now we know that number function of this
protein very low amount of the brain is
to lead to memories that this molecule
is necessary for memory and we now need
to understand how the problem starts our
memory is impaired we need to understand
how this normal regulation of the level
of this product in the brain is broken
and so the branched have to make a lot
of it so we think that through the
status and through establishing which
number function this protein we could
understand at the very beginning of the
disease and once you've usually you
understand how the disease starts which
something which you really we do not
have it so so far
what I found is that the normal function
of this protein is there to lead to
memory the opposite of memory loss so
now I would like to understand to bridge
between the normal function of this
protein which is just to lead to memory
to its abnormal function which is the
memory loss you see so the fact that the
protein gives to me gives to memory loss
it's something that it was already known
in by scientist it's a slightly
different I don't want to take credit on
something I'm not I did not I did not
discover what I have discovered is that
this protein in normal low concentration
leads to memory it leads to memory loss
the opposite only when it is there in
very I amount and i would like to bridge
the gap between its normal function and
it's pathological function it's bad
function how does the a good guy turns
into a bad guy as a good project artist
to a bad protein
one of the biggest factor that can
affect this is attention for instance I
mean if you do not pay attention to
something it's very likely that you will
learn what you have what yeah what you
just just so for instance just to make
an example that I bet the many people
may know of many of us remember what we
did on September 11 because you know
there was a coincidence just we paid
particular attention to whoa what
happened do it that day I bet that much
less people will remember what happened
the day before or two days before so
that's attention is also it's very very
important another factor that it is very
important would be motivation to if you
don't care about doing something you
would not learn about if you are
depressed or things like that you will
not learn what you have what you just
saw what you just did you would not
memorize what you just did obviously you
need to be able to perceive the stimulus
if you cannot see in a way that you will
remember us or she's not here you cannot
remember words so we need to be able to
get to to those those things this is our
staff that we help remembering obviously
those are not the only things because we
can monitor also to chemicals and two
other wastes also memories and hopefully
in the future would be even better at
that so we had an also stimulate memory
chemical II
they what I do they they will work at
the level design optical nation and
since at the time of memory there is a
chain of chemical reaction at the level
design apps became a reaction means the
same a series of protein enzyme molecule
are activated what we do we kind of
force the system artificial through this
chemical to the knowledge this chemical
to an answer to an answer memory and we
do this very well in animals and
hopefully we'll be able to do it in
people as well
how many chemicals that one can use to
enhance memory and there are many
proteins that are relevant to the
process of learning and memory for
instance all chemicals that act on a
particular gene particular gene by the
name of crab that the stimulate is gene
and they can not do in several different
ways are all molecule that in animals
work quite well at enhancing memory
they are available but we can give a
knack an extra you know additional
amount what we do in with these
chemicals we take advantage of knowledge
of what normally happens in nature and
we're a little bit push in this is any
disease is even easier because sometimes
in disease we find out one of this
chemical is less in lower amount that
what you would be normally we just help
the process by giving it artificially
with respect to that I have to say that
less than five percent of Alzheimer
disease are genetically transmitted so
ninety-five percent are not generating
transmitted and generally speaking the
one of the tar genetic transmitted they
tend to occur at earlier ages then a dog
is not a general rule but more often the
people who have it because of genetic
reasons that five percent of the people
population and have it at earlier ages
but it's only 5% that's all less than
five percent about five and all that
number
it's not that in China there is more
than America less on Europe there is
more or less than here there but there
are particular population that in a
particular circumstance that could lead
to dementia and because of the habits of
those does you know population it's just
there's more groups of people for
instance in the in the Pacific they were
population they used to eat the brain of
the dead people and then they were
transferring disease which one of the
symptoms of this disease was dementia
and they were all developing dementia so
over there there was a high incidence of
the ninja just because this habit of
heating the brain of the people that
were dead and therefore like an
infection disease they were transferring
the disease for one to end they were
higher incidence of people affected this
is once this was found in this habits
were blue and we stopped then the
incidence of disease became the same as
with another populations
in general you know if you look at our
society there is not a population of
people or you know that is more affected
by the loss of memory it is a problem
that hits with aging so something
related with the with aging and so it's
as we age we get more memory no more
memory problem obviously not all the
people are evil there are somewhat a
better memory than others and and we do
not know why some people have a better
memory than others I mean we say that
that they if we keep ourselves and our
brain exercises just like a muscle then
we tend to have memory problems less
memory problems so it kind of protective
the activity of mental activity even
some people think even physical activity
it could be protective against the
memory loss the problem problem you know
the loss of memory that's what I would
have to say obviously there are diseases
which are associated the one of the most
typical one is Alzheimer disease which
are associated with the loss of memory
and others but are less relevant unless
and the characteristic symptoms of our
symptom of our semi disease which is
really whole Markel disease is the loss
of what we call short-term memory so
that's how the disease starts actually
it's people who cannot remember what
they just did just as a very short-term
memory loss and let's last for a very
very long time and publicity the memory
problem get worse and worse and only a
day late stage of Alzheimer's disease
it's when also logical memory is
affected but the major characteristic of
Alzheimer disease which is a very
widespread disease in the population
special at old age is the loss of
short-term memory
the neurological process includes a seer
a series of chemical reaction at the
level of the sign ups and and this
series of reaction leads to changes in
the connection the synapses changes that
include both the the ISSA changes in the
receptors that are located at the
synapses such that this is a receptor
respond in a different way and change in
the release of neurotransmitter of the
synopsis and eventually changes in the
level of the morphology of the synapse
such that their synaptic response
becomes much much stronger and even an
addition to that for this memory to last
long there have to be changes in the at
the level of the genes that
that a part of our DNA and that are
long-lasting so there are genetic
changes with the formation of new
proteins in the cells and that when live
it's you know like sign its exchange in
over there as plastic changes like as
more protein and new proteins formed it
does have the sign ups you seem Emily
pass through several processes to
several point and first you memorize
something then you consolidate this
something then you can recall it when
you need to remember then you can
reconsolidate it's a process which has
several steps their faces
I bet that it depends on the particular
moment in which you are trying to recall
that memory on certain processes that no
longer happen in the brain or they are
blocked some chemical reaction cooler
and interfere or do not occur and
interfere with this process of recalling
in a certain moment and then then one
well as chance to dance to remember it
may be because you make an association
or something at the moment that house to
like you know so if you associate
something with a particular old or I
make sure an example and then that other
comes then the memory comes up just
those are tricked also to to remember
well I mean that obviously I bet that
smell is much more important for a dog
named from humans although there are
humans or exercise their sense of smell
and therefore that probably much better
than I am to remember using now I mean
there is differences different between
census a way of learning according to
the people and we are not the same it's
like a door that some people is more
open one door than another so or so they
use in one particular a more than others
so there are differences but if we
accept to the way in which the memory
gets in they came in a process that once
these things get away they are very very
similar inside the brain they are very
very similar for a different call input
memory coming from different way through
different mechanism they're very
similarly newman's and they are very
similar in between different animals
there are
way tricks that people use to learn for
is to store more numbers that way is
it's very bored to be exercised at
learning I bet that relying too much on
your notebook or your blackberry or
whatever it does not help in this
direction because we are confident that
we do not need to learn but because as I
said at the beginning attention is very
important so if you do not pay enough
attention because you write that kind of
thing then obviously you will learn less
so the secret would be just a minute
obviously if you repeat 10 times the
same thing you have more chances to
learn it or if you use association with
in what you learn with something else
and you store this association in the
brain then then you will remember that
particular thing better than another so
it's there are ways people uses and to
memorize and and then there are also
exceed an hour difference between one
person to the other for instance I'm
very bad with member numbers but a much
better will remember geographical names
location etc so I bet there are people
are better remember don't use notes and
music than others depends also what you
like it what you don't like just because
you pay more attention to what you liked
and what you don't like
as I said before the only thing this
issuer is just to exercise your brain
and just like you do with the gym know
with your muscles and that's for sure
should help because the brain we have to
see the brain also like like an organ it
has a reserve so if we built up bigger
reserve then when diseases will heat or
the memory program we will start
occurring we will have more time to
compensate for the for the problem so it
diseases should be start later and
slower and just not that we will avoid
the disease but it almost likely what we
scientists think most likely happen is
just with more reserved in the brain so
that's for sure I have to say also that
although it needs to be confirmed
validated and one cannot exclude it to
end up like with the aluminum story that
you know people say that died like the
Mediterranean diet with the present of
antioxidant this kind of stuff in your
type they should protect and against the
problem like how some of these or be
more protected which does not mean again
that the does not mean that it will not
happen but it will happen there will be
less incidence of Alzheimer disease in
this population or population that eat
fish and fish so this time is obviously
we have to be careful because there's
things showing it but they might not be
confirmed in the future but that's what
in the exercise and eating healthy
it's not totally memory also others
problems
whatever you you like to do and it's not
just yet to take it like a pill now I
have to do trend across word puzzle and
instead of five it does not it doesn't
work like that it just to be involved
with your life and and being active and
not fortunately when sometime people
become all that they tend to be less
stressed out by life and they are that
tend to be depressed so let's involve
this interesting so that's the thing is
just to be active mentally active and to
be mentally active I bet you need to
like what you are doing i mean you
cannot oblige yourself to be mentally
active i have to be mentally that i
don't think it works like that
it happens and most likely you are
storing things in the brain and you're
confusing for me your fantasy with the
reality and were you one possibility the
other possibility like he had the wrong
perception of what you saw so you store
in a certain way because you're
convinced that that it's that way but it
was not that way if let's say
a stupid example I mean you're convinced
that maybe were not did not pay that
much attention and you convince that
person was just in red instead was pink
or a color close to read then then you
you store the thing in that that way
obviously with time and the memory will
become more far away certain aspect
could disappear and we could fill them
with other aspect just to fill the gap
so we make up for the memory and we
build up the memory and the time of
recalling the memory we are recording
stuff that occurred in other
circumstances because I mean it's a
memory it's not our brain is not there a
recorder like passive recording it's a
more active process so being an active
process there are could be ways of you
know changing it because actively we can
we can change so that's something which
is important it's not that word brain is
like a tape recorder or a TV or vcr I
mean it's not the lattice it was more
active than that and there are several
steps in the process of memory and
recalling a memory which there are many
many steps several steps and each one of
them as memory could be labelled and
could be you know changed doing for
something else which you do by something
else
visitor you have to look at member as a
process in which there are several steps
which they imply some I say some
interference friend it's not the right
word processing of our brain of this
information and this it's just purely
active and it has changed it's like when
you change something from analog to
digital just to make one of those things
not the video from the computer and in
that process of changing from analog to
digital you can change something and
will not be the same you know what if
you change the chip or something and you
change the yellow into a green so what
there was yellow will be green and or a
when I say nay you can even artificially
change it to into a B if you want
because if you tell the computer to
change all the a into a bit and
everything would be a baby or sometimes
you this process some may will changing
their be done will change just some
activity something that is they are
occurring and it changes
you